[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je croyais pouvoir t'aimer jusqu'à la
nuit des temps je croyais que notre
amour pourrait durer longtemps je me
rappelle encore le jour où je t'ai connu
mon amour était mort et puis tu es venu
j'avais besoin d'amour et tu as su
m'imer au bout de quelques jours
revenent les regrets mais toi tu étais
as déjà comme un scalet tu avais besoin
de moi tu avais pas de regret un peu
plus chaque jour je m c'est mon cœur qui
te parlait d'amour pour consoler tes
pleurs je croyais pourir taimer jusqu'à
la nuit des temps je croyais que notre
amour pourrait durer longtemps mais je
sais qu'aujourd'hui je ni au fond de moi
que chagrin et ennuie dès que je
t'aperçois que ton regard au mien
sournoisement s'accroche il y a moins de
chagrin qu'il M a de rep proche et ne
reste pas là là me regarder il n'y a pas
que moi que tu es pu aimé ne me reproche
pas nos anciennes folies quand je pars
ne dis pas que j'en met de ta
vie je croyais pouvoir m'aimer jusqu'à
ton dernier jour tu croyais que ton
chagrin allait durer toujours mais je
sais que demain notre amour viendra il
te prendra la main et il t'emmènera
alors tu oublieras tous nos chers
souvenir qui tont parler de moi et de
notre avenir tu reverras le printemps tu
verras tes 20 ans à nouveau les serments
et passera le temps que tu diras un jour
en lui montrant la Prance à ton dernier
amour que le diable t'emporte que le
diable t'emporte que le diable t'emporte
que le diable
[Musique]
t'enorte